voilà la communication verrouillée dans
chaque camp on va le voir dans quelques
instants également côté
ukrainien à main charrier bonjour
revenons d'abord peut-être sur cette
prise de parole de Vladimir Poutine qui
était évidemment attendu tout le
week-end il aura fallu attendre de
longues heures hier au final une brève
déclaration 11 minutes je crois savoir
tout ça pour dire quoi exactement il a
pris le temps de faire une vidéo quand
même et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on voit bien qu'on est dans une
politique intérieure russe à ce moment
là il se repositionne en tant que
président et en tant que chef et il
assure au Russe que il n'y a pas eu de
bain de sang dans son pays en disant il
y avait une tentative de déstabilisation
sous-entendu l'Occident l'Ukraine
sous-entendu encore plus clair les
Américains qui du coup immédiatement ont
rappelé que il revendiquait d'être pas
du tout intervenu dans ce qui s'est
passé mais la position de la lumière
Poutine c'était de dire on voulait
monter russe contre russe on aurait pu
avoir des bains de sang on aurait pu
avoir des effusions beaucoup plus larges
et beaucoup plus violente et donc il a
rappelé tout le monde au calme il a
remercié les musiciens que ce soit de
Wagner ou des autres groupes de ne pas
avoir continué et d'être allé plus loin
en quelque sorte et puis voilà on en est
là à ce moment précis qu'est-ce qui va
ça qu'est-ce que ça va enclencher
derrière est-ce que derrière on va avoir
un Vladimir Poutine qui va être un peu
affaibli est-ce qu'on va voir émerger un
autre une autre personnalité ou alors
est-ce que ça va rester en l'état on va
suivre au fur et à mesure des jours les
comptes qui vont pour être réglés alors
juste avant cette cette prise de parole
Eugénie prégoji lui aussi était sorti de
son silence dans un message radio il
fait aussi une courte déclaration il
n'avait pas pris la parole lui non plus
il sait pas justifié non il ne s'est pas
justifié parce qu'il n'a pas voulu
parler de tentative de coup d'État il a
dit jusque en fait ce qu'il avait
conduit à mener ces troupes aussi loin
en Russie parce que quand même c'était
des qui était sorti avec des armes et
c'était pour se poser contre la décision
qui avait été demandé par shoyu qui
était de mettre les hommes de Wagner
sous contrat avec l'armée russe alors ça
c'est une réalité c'est vrai que
lorsqu'il était allé jusqu'à Roscoff et
qu'ensuite il avait demandé non pas à
parler à Vladimir Poutine mais il avait
demandé soit des racima chef
d'état-major soit égo qui est le
ministre de la Défense
les experts avaient anticipé qui avait
eu un problématique avec eux et c'est
vrai que la demande de schweigou qui
était de dire les hommes de Wagner
doivent rentrer sous contrat à partir du
1er juillet avec l'armée russe change
largement le statut parce que ça veut
dire que dans ce cas là on est plus avec
des miliciens on est avec des hommes qui
passent dans une armée on est plus ou
commandement de trigogine et surtout on
est plus non plus avec la même capacité
j'allais dire de s'enrichir parce que je
vous rappelle que tous ces hommes
lorsqu'ils font des combats que ce soit
en Afrique que ce soit en Syrie que ce
soit en Ukraine il y a les combats et
derrière évidemment il y a aussi
l'enrichissement et ça derrière lequel
il s'est il s'est camouflé en disant ce
qui m'a conduit c'était ceci qui m'a
inquiété qui m'a intrigué et voilà on en
est resté là pour l'instant il n'y a pas
de héros